BRENNON EDWARDS:
When I was a kid,
I always wanted to be
a marine biologist.
And I was the person
that would always
be spouting off random facts.
Like did you know a blue whale
can be 110 feet long, like just
to people I didn't even know.
And I always felt
that there's something
that we can learn from them.
What really attracted
me to the program
was the idea that I would
be able to still do science.
My role is a volunteer
citizen scientist.
What I do is I fly my drones on
the beaches on the California
coast to help map and determine
the effects of El Nino.
MATT MERRIFIELD:
This year, California
is experiencing a sort of
unprecedented El Nino event.
We've got very extreme weather.
And given how strong it is
gives us a sort of crystal ball
about what sea
level rise and what
climate change is going
to look like in the future
along the California coast.
Using phones or drones,
UAVs, to document that change
would be a good way to do that.
So we've asked people
to take photos of events
where there's been real
high water along the coast
or water that's been
overtopped dunes or inundating
coastal areas.
So we'll end up with
larger pository of photos.
And once we have
that information,
we'll use the geospatial
information in the photos
to map because the
phone photos actually
have a location tag with them.
BRENNON EDWARDS: There's
a lot of factors that
go into what areas that I map.
Everyone loves going
to the beaches,
and I normally make
a day out of it.
What the Nature Conservancy
has us looking for
is signs of erosion or
change on the coastlines,
and things that you can tell are
happening because of the water.
I tend to just kind of
go back to the same spot
and just see if I can notice a
difference from what I've done.
Another big reason that I
really wanted to be involved
was that there's a lot of
publicity about drones,
and a lot of it isn't
necessarily good.
There's a lot of
that drones can do
that are good for the
community and for the world,
and it's just getting
the word out there.
MATT MERRIFIELD: So mapping
typically in the past
has either been done
with satellite imagery
or aerial photography.
The benefit of
drones is the ability
to actually go out and capture
things that happen really
quickly and then go away.
You couldn't necessarily
task a satellite for it
to be right at the right
place for those four hours.
BRENNON EDWARDS: The thing that
I like about being a citizen
scientist is that I know that
I'm being a part of something
bigger than me.
I'm contributing to something
good that's helping everyone.
This protects the
beauty of California,
so why wouldn't
you want to do this
if it's something that's free
for you, it's easy to do,
and honestly it's fun?
Why not?
SUBJECT 1: Please be sure
to watch this next episode
about a woman who completely
changed the concept of school
to combat poverty.
SUBJECT 2: If all you can
do is make it to school,
we'll take care of the
rest-- food, clothes, shoes,
health care.
SUBJECT 3: What kind
of changes did you
start to see in your students
when you will started
to remove those barriers?
SUBJECT 2: So when kids
knew that we cared,
there was almost like
this light bulb went off,
this willingness to try.
SUBJECT 1: Thanks for
watching and sure to subscribe
to Seeker Stories.